Dell has just updated their XPS 13 laptop
for 2019, and we got the entry-level i5 model
for $1150, which is a great price considering
it packs 8GB of RAM and 256gigs of NVMe SSD
storage.
So let’s go through everything you need
to know about it.
Just like last year, it’s encased in an
aluminum shell that looks and feels great
compared to many other Windows laptops.
The display has very thin great-looking bezels,
despite the fact that they’ve moved the
webcam back up above the display.
Last year’s model had the webcam under the
display to accommodate Windows Hello, a useful
feature that scans your face to log you in
without having to enter your password.
That feature is now gone, but it’s not a
big deal since the power button doubles as
a fingerprint scanner for logging in.
The display itself uses a 1080P panel that
definitely isn’t the sharpest display out
there, but the excellent color accuracy and
matte filter make it one of the better 1080P
displays you can find.
But either way, if you care a lot about the
display, we’d recommend upgrading to the
4K model for a few hundred dollars more.
The keyboard feels pretty decent for a Windows
laptop with a good amount of travel.
Typing is pretty comfortable, but some users
did complain that there was a bit too much
spacing between the keys.
Personally, we prefer the latest MacBook pro
keys which are wider and more clicky, but
most people will prefer the Dells.
It also features backlighting with two brightness
settings so it’s great for using at night.
The build quality is really solid and doesn’t
flex like other cheaper Windows laptops do.
One thing we can complain about is that there’s
no notch in the front to help open up the
laptop, so you kind of have to jam your fingernail
in there to open it up, and the hinge is pretty
stiff so it’s tough to open with one hand.
The trackpad is also pretty good for a Windows
laptop, but you definitely won’t get the
same experience as with one of the newer MacBooks,
which feature the best trackpads in the business.
But the XPS 13’s trackpad is still above
average, really only getting topped by Huawei’s
MateBook X Pro and the Razer Blade Stealth.
One thing that really stands out about the
new XPS 13 is that it packs a total of three
full-speed USB-C ports, with two of them supporting
full-speed Thunderbolt 3, and the port on
the right side has now been upgraded to USB
3 gen 1 which is twice as fast as last year.
A lot of other Windows laptops only come with
just one Thunderbolt 3 port or two slower
ones, so having two full-speed ports is impressive.
It also packs a mini-SD card slot, a headphone
jack, and a neat little battery indicator
button that shows you the current battery
life.
One thing that still disappoints us year over
year is the speaker quality.
It sounds okay but it definitely lacks volume
and a wide range of frequency reproduction.
A few years ago, these types of speakers were
the norm, but many windows laptops have been
making big improvements.
The 720P webcam actually isn’t too bad,
using noise reduction to make for a clear
but not as sharp image, but the microphone
quality was really terrible.
Just listen for yourself.
On the plus side, battery life is also really
impressive compared to last year, but that’s
using the default battery saving settings.
If you leave it on these settings, you’ll
get decent performance similar to base 13”
dual-core MacBook Pro, which is not what you’d
expect from its i5 quad-core processor.
But if you turn on best performance mode,
you’ll gain a lot of extra processing power.
And we saw the same results for the graphics
as well.
Compared to last year, we’re getting a ton
of graphics performance.
This is probably one of the biggest standout
features of the laptop.
It’s really powerful for the price, so it
can handle things like entry-level video or
photo editing really well, and you can handle
simple 4K video editing.
However, we’re a bit disappointed with the
NVMe storage speed, it’s not too bad, but
we really hope it’ll speed up next year.
But either way, If you’re someone who’s
looking for a good quality laptop with great
performance for around the $1000 range, the
Dell XPS 13 is a good choice.
It’s a great laptop overall with only a
couple of downsides that many regular users
may not mind, and at a price of just $1150,
it’s a really good value.
If you’re someone that will be using the
laptop in bright environments or watching
a lot of video content and music, you might
want to look elsewere.
The Huawei Matebook Pro X would be a great
alternative but with everything that has been
going on with Huawei recently, its a tough
sell.
If you've got some extra cash, definitely
look into the 4K model of the XPS 13, or maybe
even one of the higher-end XPS 15 models which
pack dedicated graphics and six-core processors.
If you’re also considering buying an Apple
MacBook, you should definitely check out our
comparison between the XPS 13 and the base
13” MacBook Pro.
If you enjoyed this review, tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!